why is the ocean salty and rivers aren't
in fact most of the salt in the sea
comes from Rivers but how can that be it
all starts with ocean water heading out
on the journey warm surface water
evaporates the water vapor then Rises to
condense into clouds that sometimes get
carried over land where they rain down
again on their way down the water
droplets absorb CO2 and become slightly
acidic when they Splash onto stones and
soil they wash out sorts of minerals as
ions and feed them into rows from there
the salts travel to some lake or the
ocean where they can accumulate over
time after animals and plants Feast on
this mineral Buffet sodium and chloride
ions remain as leftovers you know them
assault it's responsible for the
salinity of ocean water because the
ocean deposits as much salt sediment on
the seafloor as Rivers feed into it the
salt level stays at a stable 35 grams
per liter on average rivers in turn do
not accumulate salt they simply deliver
the minerals in the little traces of
salt to the oceans and lakes what goes
in comes out
[Music]